Merhaba
bizim için özür dilerim başlayacağım bu
ara biraz yoğun bir tempo var
yalnız burada olmaktan çok mutlu oldum
söylemeden geçemeyeceğim pırıl pırıl
deyişler Benim ilk aklıma gelen bir
şeydir bizim bu gençlere yeni gelecek
ekmek dillere borç mu
benim öğretmenlerimle eğlenceli 25 yıl
devlette çalıştım ama edebiyat öğretmeni
dediği gibi öğretmeni bir türlü emekli
olamam demiştim ona
Hadi hadi
şey öğretmen
[Müzik]
Bunun anlamı şuydu bir kelime geçiyor da
onun Köy olarak nerede çıktı
Sonra geçtiği yollarda niye demiştin
fikir üretmek olduğunda öğrendiklerinde
Avrupa'ya işte bir yerde eğitimler
oluyor ötürü
öğretmenimizdir aklına en çok
öğrencilerden öğrendiğini itiraf etmeden
aklım karıştığında çocuklara karşı
inanılan Eğer bakkiyat yapmıyorlar
inanılmaz
bizim kuşağın
yaşayanları öğretmenleri pek çok
öğretmen Arkadaşım şu anda kurulan
okullar başlarında ve okullarda farklı
uygulamalarda
yapılıyor Çünkü
öğretmen lazım
deneyime dayanmaktadır
[Müzik]
on iki bir şeylerden devam etmekten
çekiyorlar genellikle kapalı olur
Jandarma gelebilirler
birden beni o günleri götürdü
Biraz önce
gençlerin anlattığı gibi
Yörük de gelmeyin Hani dünyada normal
geliyor ama geliyor O kültür aynen
duruyor doğa ile o yakın ilişkiler
oluyor
okumayı temel teknolojiyi
binlerce benim
Ama
evin yanında Resuller falan
biliyor musun ki o zaman çok büyük yok
tu
bile giderdiği
işlere Buradan gönderiyorum
lütfen
evrakta kendi bilirler
coğrafyası
olmakta olmak
nar suyu geldiğinde ben daha doğrusu o
alarmı
çok ilginçtir hani diğer yerlerden
farklı olarak Karadeniz'e
ilginç
bir tarihe
20 yıldır bir arkadaşımız
vardı
O benim düşündü bizim için olmayan kişi
olmak için gerekli Bu da çocukluğunda
yatıyor Çünkü
Demek ki yetişmiş
bunun en iyi düşük ne derdi düşmanlıkta
yani onu Anadolu'ya da bir karşılığı var
konuş bakın çocuklara bak hoş geçiyor
dedi ağlayan çocuğumuz iktidar ne demek
acaba zaten bana derlerdi niye bu kadar
anlattın yani
bu
ne
başımızı gökyüzüne kaldırdığında
önemli çocuklarla gülümsemeye başlarlar
oynarken
o zaman geçmişi Evet
kendi modellerine gidiyorlar olmanın
yolu buradan geçiyor demek ki Bu markayı
kullanmak gerekiyor
çokça daha iyi geliyordu
Bizim büyükler de büyükler de kuşaklar
arasında kalabalık içinde olmak da bu
öğrenmeyi teşvik ediyor
lar Çünkü doğduğun köyünde muhteşem
geçmenliğinde vardı
Avşarlar yürürler 20 kere Ceyhan'da da
öyle çok farklı insanlar ziyarete
Bu bir alışkanlık
eder önemli insanlar
bunlar
Çocuklar okulda erkekleri
farklı şeylere yapmaktır hükmettim
barışmaktır
o bilgiler
eğer ondan sonra kalkarken biraz doğru
gidiyorum arkamı geçiyor öğretmen
ler ne yapar Her
iki değil öldüğünüzde çıktı
çocuğun kendini iyileştirmek içerisine
koymak konusunda da özel nihatlar
öğretmenler arasında
Hayır nereye gider
im
ve
eğitim
şeyi öğrenmek istemediğinden her
kötülüğü sorusunu Aldattım karma alırım
üstündeki hakikatta dezavantaj duruma
düşüyor elde etti var öğrenmek zordurlar
öğretmen olarak gitti öğretmen zorluyor
Biz de okumalıyız
onların sayesinde çok eğitim aldım
epey bir şey öğrenme şansım oldu
ve
dediğim gibi şirkette gençler takımında
noktaya geldi
demek
ki
farkındalık konusunda bir Doğanlar için
türlü dediklerimi imkanlar
'dan uzaklaşmış Gerçi öğretmenlik
öğretmenliği
çocuklar için
ama belli dedim ya
Yani bu milletin kültürü var diye
coğrafyasıdır
o binlerce Yıldırım
oldu
Biraz önce Türklerden bahsediyorduk
orman değil yolda
değilim
Türklerle bağlamaya
[Müzik]
bir inceleyin bakalım Neler oluyor orada
bunlar önemli şeyler Hani ben minik
minik dolaşarak Bu arada Eskiden
bildiğini kaybedip buldum Örneğin geri
dönüşümlerle her şeyin şeye dönüşüyordu
Bu da yakın
daha inceledik
leri
paylaşmış gibi çocuklarla
yani
ondan sormasını
yardımlaşma
Ne yapabilirim Bunu yapabiliyor ne biçim
çocuklarla gençlerle çelişeler Onların
da dokunmaları
ne ezber bozulduğunda İnanmaz keşiflerle
çıkıyorlar çok farklılık bekarlığına
doğadan koparak
ekip olarak veril
ebilir hayatta kalmamız
mı kendinizi düşünüyorlar
madridge yüzlerce yıl önce söylemiş bir
şeyi kaybedip bulmaca
çok güzel çok sevindiğim şeyler var ki
Hidayet nedir
bilmiyorum
şu anda ülkemizde olan bir
işaret etti
tohumun Bankası topraktır internet
toprağa defadır en defanınızla bunu
yaparsınız hem de kuşaklar arası
Öğrenmeyi de şimdi başlıyor küçük
aileler halinde yaşıyor kalabalık
değildir büyükler Yok
kalabalıklar yok sanki yaş grupları yok
Dolayısıyla şartları
yapan bitkilerden bir örnek vereceğim
bizim orada yabani
Yani bir çeşit birkaç
inek kurtarabilirdi
[Müzik]
yaptıkça Bakın şu Karnıma güzel bence
çok sağ olun birbirinize Bir de Arada
sohbet etmeyi imkanı bulursa bu belli
bir noktaya gelir Dolayısıyla
Tekbir yokmuş
Hanım
[Alkış]